i want people to start grading my
material you know we are getting a lot
of people writing in and caroline sent
them to me we have a message from lacey
that had a prank
oh that's what i wanted you to do all
right let me hear you she said howie got
a prank my partner and i are currently
working on a pot farm in mendocino
california this is our second year with
an incredibly sweet couple that has been
hosting us while we work on their farm
while parents are grateful that we are
with good people that are taking care of
us this isn't exactly ideal in their
eyes i thought it would be hilarious if
we called my mom saying the farm got
raided and we are being questioned by
the police you could be a cop
um in question the parents yeah no
saying letting them know that their
daughter yeah yeah
and they said we are there until the end
of this month so it'll have to be kind
of soon hope to hear from you guys okay
so what's the idea you're going to call
the parents i'm going to call the
parents i'm going to call the parents
because they're already like iffy about
her working on a pot farm oh it's a pot
farm yeah so i actually i talked to
lacey too and she was super excited
about calling her parents names are anne
and robbie
the whole post do you see the number up
there howie what do you see the number
right here
yeah okay great you want me to call it
sure okay we'll just play it by ear i'll
just have adam robbie what their names
are ann and robbie
okay
and we have an okay to do this right
yes i talked to lacy well i don't care
from lacey but the parents don't know
right lou do you want to put on your
headphones so you can hear what they're
no it's better when he does it's better
jackie okay he can he can't hear the
prank oh yeah he should do it
we'll let you put on here like i'll hear
the damn prank okay i don't know if it's
a prank but i love when people give me
stuff to do we have a lot coming in now
there's more okay okay uh let's try this
okay and whose parent is this lacie this
is lacey lacy's yeah yes and what's uh
miss
okay yes
mr and mrs oh they're busy
they're probably on the line to some you
know what she thinks that the parents
are mad they're probably calling uh a
pot they forgot to hang up that's what
the problem is they were on the phone
they got high and they forgot the hang
no you don't understand i think you
typed it in right you don't think i did
i'll try it again i'll try it again why
do you think i did it wrong in the
meantime
uh
lu i mean uh jackie tell them what
you've been up to
what have i been up to tell the audience
not much
just hanging out at home with my kids
we've been on the podcast okay here we
go told you you did it wrong
hello hello is that anne
hello
hello there's not a there's not an
uh are you familiar with a lacie
yes uh are you related
yes oh no she's fine i'm this is
lieutenant howard
um
and i'm in charge of the case uh you're
familiar with the
the raid that happened last night
no on the uh
cannabis farm
no
oh um well
we are in the midst of a deportation
everybody uh
i think she was the only american on the
farm but uh they are all being deported
to nicaragua
the all the all the uh farm workers and
she is and there was another uh
young lady uh by the name of robbie also
so
yeah so they are going to be in
nicaragua they should be landing in
about two hours so we will need their
paperwork
i i don't understand what you're saying
okay um are you familiar that they were
involved in the raid yeah yesterday oh
they work on a cannabis they work on a
cannabis farm
did you know that
yes
so you are aware of that
yes and you condone that no i do not
oh well they had given your name and
your number they are nick they're on
their way to nicaragua
uh where they've been deported uh well
you realize that cannabis growing the
way they were growing it in a uh
in a uh it was a
though they were using the fields of the
uh elementary schools to grow uh
pot
are you joking me no
no i thought it wa you know i was given
this number to
get the paperwork because of nicaragua
we want to make sure that uh we put them
with cell mates that speak the same
languages so we're going to need
uh information i don't understand why
she would go to nicaragua
everybody working the farm and working
the plants are nicaraguan so we don't
have time to disseminate who is from who
she has given us the information
there in nicaragua right now or on their
way and what we want to do is put them
with a uh a cellmate that we feel that
she would be comfortable with and she
gave us your name
now the fact that you are aware of what
was going on
um is there any way he told me it was
legal it was a legal
place can i ask you something
yes
how legal
is growing cannabis
in the uh fields of an elementary school
not at all
i i'm i'm in shock right now okay why
why am i in shock but you knew she was
working there and she has given your
name
we are going to do a uh full search of
your uh residence
also um and we are going to have to have
you if uh and we're gonna work on the
honor system now because i assume that
you are an honest person to give
yourself a strip search can we do that
now while we are on the phone
what are you talking about i want to
know if there's any uh cannabis where
you are or if you're hiding it in any
orifice or whatever this is a federal
case
um if this is a federal case then why
don't you just come to my house
well ma'am i you know i will just funny
is this a joke no
yes it is a joke no it's not
then why were you laughing i did not
laugh
i don't know where you heard laughter i
coughed
if you want to come search something you
just need to come and find me and come
get me
and go to my house and go search the
house all right do everything else you
need to do and are you are you okay with
the strip search
i do not have
it i i do not have a female detective
right now and this is why you know and
in these times
i'm asking the honor system if you could
just search yourself and that's what i'm
asking
and i uh right now otherwise i will
pause yourself
search yourself i'm not searching
nothing please ma'am
no
well ma'am do you want me to pull the
paperwork then i will pull the paperwork
please do
why are you being so
obstinate like why
i don't understand your point of view as
far as this is concerned
i don't understand why you're calling
about this why
uh she gave us your name and your number
i don't know what your relationship is
to these
people but this is with the number
mother okay i'm her mother okay so your
daughter is on her way to nicaragua
your daughter is uh
lauren
no
so you don't even know the name i have a
few names here
okay
so
er and
i i've got names listen the paperwork we
just did the raid last night ma'am i
have a lot going on
i have ann robbie lorne
lacy
lysey is my daughter okay
lacey is the ringleader lacey
was the person in charge of keeping the
children away from the cannabis at the
elementary school
when we went to the field she was
holding six children back from the
cannabis
hello
yeah
okay
i will take a statement now
go ahead
this is being recorded
okay okay you can record anything you
want i don't know i know i'm allowed to
uh by federal luck go ahead
i i don't have any statement i i don't
know what to say
well
start with the uh abbreviations and then
move on to uh any quotes
go ahead ma'am
i i don't have anything else to say
[Music]
all right
then uh i will hold on while you strip
search yourself
okay go ahead
pat yourself down
anything around start the ankles
tell me
start at the end that's the most
ridiculous thing i've ever heard in my
life ma'am
i think it's ridiculous growing cannabis
in a schoolyard
asking somebody whether they are holding
or
why are you telling me like i know this
i'm asking you to pat yourself down
and tell me what is feeling start at the
legs start at the ankles
that is ridiculous why is that
ridiculous have you never
seen anything like this before pat
yourself
i'm asking th you don't want to do it in
the honor system you want me to send
somebody to to do the hunter system of
patting yourself that's the most
ridiculous thing i've ever heard in my
life i don't understand what you're
saying
why is that ridiculous
how do i know you're not concealing
hello
i better call back
you have to tell her at some point like
what if
oh yeah she's going to call her daughter
i'm going to call i'll tell her now i'll
tell her now because our guests are here
so i want i want the guests to come in
okay
i better tell her
i better tell her
she's probably calling her now no she's
probably calling her daughter but it's
her daughter's idea i didn't ask her to
do it
no
all right um
we have some very famous youtube stars
here one of my favorite
people
huge stars they are
no i know
have you ever worked with uh i love it
you've reached aunt
and
you can't just leave it no i don't want
to leave it i called and she didn't
answer okay let me try again
i can't leave it this is a pr this could
be a problem she's calling her it could
be a problem but her daughter knows her
daughter gave permission can we call
give me your daughter's call her
daughter now yeah i can get you that
hold on hold on
caroline's on top of it she told you
that
should i try calling on my phone
she won't recognize your number
you think of my numbers coming up on her
phone
i think so i have a blocked call to
federal agency oh okay this mr friday
dragging it
she won't answer now no
i love it you every sand i know anne
poor anne sorry anne i apologize anne
you should be ashamed of yourself
no caroline caroline you ruined the
family that mother is freaking out
she hung up on me i can't tell her this
was all going to be fun in games and now
she thinks she's got a daughter in
nicaragua in a cell with not the right
cellmate and she is at home patting
herself down trying to find cannabis in
her ass because of you caroline i hope
you are happy young lady you are ruining
people's lives that's what i do i know
that's what i do well wait till we see
the comments next week from you yeah
mrs beautiful who ruins strangers lives
i texted you her number
whose
lacy i'm trying to get ann
i'm trying to get ann
hello hey anne
yeah hi i've got a number for you it's
how we made this number it's howie
mandel
no way yeah
yeah
now will you pat yourself down
your daughter made me do this no your
daughter maybe my daughter
she made me an idiot
[Laughter]
now i'm laughing your daughter's an
idiot
yes so this is my pleasure i'm an idiot
yeah maybe i don't know you don't kill
you lacie when i see you i'm gonna choke
the life out of you
that's nice that's parenting people
don't people aren't good parents anymore
and i like the way you deal with your
children that's the way they need she is
wherever she is she wrote in my daughter
and my daughter's right here say hi to
my daughter hi
that's jacqueline
so she wrote a daughter yeah i do
and uh
my my i think my daughter sometimes is
an idiot too so we have a lot in common
lacey lacy wrote into our podcast we do
a podcast where we do prank phone calls
and stuff occasionally and she wrote in
and told us that she works on a
marijuana farm and that you're not
thrilled about the idea and that we
should prank you
this is her line exactly i thought it
would be hilarious if we called my mom
saying that the farm got raided and we
were being questioned by the police she
thought that might be hilarious do you
agree ann
that's a lot oh my gosh just call me
howard believe
i cannot believe it uh well that
i'm telling you i have never been gotten
so
so bad did you pat yourself down with my
no i'm not patting myself down
what did you do when we got off when you
hung up on me who'd you phone i called
my husband and he was like and there's
something up with that were you
considering patting yourself down
i almost did yeah yeah it was very close
very close to patting herself down
because it was it was the honor system
well and you're you're you're a real joy
thank you for being part of the show we
got to go now because we actually have
things to do thank you that we play
okay i love you oh yeah now you can't
take that back you called her an idiot
and you were gonna choke
her we're calling uh uh
uh children's protective services now
i'll talk to you later bye-bye that'll
be the next call yeah okay bye bye
lacey's gonna end up on a true crime
podcast what happened to lady anyways
the guests are all here
[Music]